ciò un sorriso a 12.000 denti e non sono
neanche sporchi perché in questo
episodio abbiamo [ __ ] il tesoro del
del mondo proprio del mondo o unito due
video insieme perché ha una certa o gli
occhiali e non vi spaventate sono
chiarite adiposi ogni tanto li mette
però vi lascio a uno dei video più fighi
che abbia mai fatto su si artista
buona visione dall'alto del suo perché
entrato in modalità di quel centro
possiamo mettere in prigione equipaggio
o il portiere in mano diventano anche le
8 molto divertente deve fare la calabria
questa cella in camping a 20 che base si
mare un non so dicono sia per uscire da
questa galera ma più tra noi saremo noi
dobbiamo avere tutti a sfregio e poi
vomitargli tutti in faccia regalo non è
una bella cosa questa da vedere bene
questo scacco
ecco cervello che vaga e gekas ed a
forma di feticismo pietro è la musica
molto si merita questa scena finale dei
player si ortiz è vero che regga
problemi che è brutta scena raga
veramente io ho pagato 70 euro per
quello esatto recensire il gioco può
imitare in faccia pietro 10 su 10 bene
sicuramente finita nel modo migliore che
potessi starnuti o dei minatori non aver
soldi sotto la 36 acqua sei tu che è
successo di 6 punti vedo obiettivo è
caduto e senza fisica sotto il fondo
dell'oceano nuova beh ecco spiegate
facendo profughi ai sei seduto nel mezzo
della ci stai
stai torna di superficie così bellissimo
dove più grazie noce cd dvd baule di
quelli che chiedono di superficie
stiamo andando al raid dove c'è già una
nave c'è un bug e ragazzi mi sento
pietro mentre suona vice suona suona
suona zona ti prego quanto ci hanno
messo però correggere pietro in questo
gioco grazie a dio non super quad avanti
credi che modica non i canoni caracciolo
che sta spara tutti dall'altra nave meno
male a noi non ci sta cagando occhio
tirare giù le vele però perché siamo
troppo veloci sta girando la dalla nave
sta girando con lo sviluppo occhio
d'amico in mamma mia che schifo
porca vacca escluso tutto lo sviluppo e
santa ordinario lo sviluppo lega arriva
ce n'è tanto il centro contro by day aia
che male ai ac ha incornato fortissimo e
ci prova ci provo allora vicini e ci
provo ci provo
eccomi al un tesoro non tesoro ok la
nave affondata e hanno un teschio easy
ok crociera oggi stanno salendo sulla
strana verità sarà un barile e stanno
bene
usando un bari ma sempre con strana vi
aiuto a chi sta per esplodere sapreste
una delle barile esploso borca porca un
ragazzi ad una mano su tutto serve che
lo uccido una mano sotto arrivare io
arrivavo sta arrivando non ammazza gli
schermi
ho passato una squadra ci parlano
sono sparate
non l'ho mai fatto
con uno scopo
mamma mia ragazzi disastro non ho
preferito ho finito tutte le k league
hanno neanche io sparo
ecco mi pare un burro 1 solo dicendo i
borghi sai almeno uno cina medici un
medici 11 la vita tutto anche l'oro o
perfetto che fa piacere ma noi lo stand
armi visto per sapere
no non lo stanno affondando vero anch'io
ci sarà quella sfortuna da noi e forse
sono anche dove sai la maledizione no
niente non sono fondati mi hanno fatto
quadrato preso proprio occhio solo n 1 è
ecco c'è una sopra quesito e non muore
che devo dire che cosa facendo leva
spararsi sulla zona vero che
e va bene ragazzo andati
1 seriano cuore sta arrivando qua lo
vedo io mi sparo sulla loro nave
perfetto che mira che ciò brown violis
li butto giù la nave è lo stesso a farli
fuori prima che riparino
ok non ucciso regalano avere ucciso è ok
e ucciso stanno affondando forse
affondano non te lo so dire se lo ha
colpito un paio di volte senso affondano
acceso in vita la figlia colpite lavoro
colpiti ancora una volta vi prego io
sono aperto pasqua bravo perfetto
bravissimo a posto dalla fondano a fondo
in fondo non si corroso modo tutti dice
uno è morto lega ok
ok arcavacata ucciso abbia detto che non
è andata all'andata sono andati che è
sicuro al cento per cento e al 1000
marcatori camente adesso dovremmo poter
fare il santo padre
ok
ieri con le munizioni e diesel mentre
salgo la scala devi fare questa cosa qua
della tegola sito blog
è molto facile
ultimamente bollito o lamento bo sito
ora non sparate non vedo una nave vede
non ave quello ma se sollevati contro di
noi ma barcaccia vacche per no dai uno
scherzo
c'è un galeone vero che facciamo
lasciamo perdere il rating è la ragazza
è solo una delle sue navi face lo
sviluppo che sta attaccando con poi
hanno visto attaccando a voi non è
cambiata la musica come se ci fosse
anche il capitano c'è capitano non ci
credo
allora farlo fuori ci sono un capitano è
morto
la chiave ed ora me ne vado vado a
suonare fermi venite qua banale ceriale
io abbia e ma non abbiamo una cosa noi
particolare per la patata va beh no
andiamo una nave non abbiamo in questo
momento lega siamo affrontati e potrebbe
essere un'opzione plausibile e momento
come signori dire con un'altra nardino
sonora fondata sul principio dei vini
quella nave nuovo anche se si sta
avviando crono c'è quello c'è il nemico
che sta cercando la chiave
tu lo sai io sono o no nel vero forse
adesso non lo so ma nessuno ha visto una
pa che stiamo andando navi è questo che
di sicuro sta facendo fuori un po non di
per la chiave la mobilità della chiave
ma no io la chiave l'omessa sull'isola
in un punto abbastanza nascosto trattavo
gesto prima dovevamo scappare questa era
la foto di non vendere prima quindi deve
essere fatta questa qua andiamo un po
qua siamo fieri ha fatti fuori tutti
lega
ok non fatti fuori 36 moto sì mi ha
fatto fuori tre però mai nascosto dietro
la chiave si era nascosto abbastanza
bene ha fatto ho fatto fuori il capitano
fatto fuori in ondata di raid a sordi la
chiavennasca ho fatto fuori tre dei vizi
sinistra sinistra tedesco c'è uno
scoglio destro e tiro a giro che conta a
dame to coast città
ebbene allora non si ancora non scappate
dalla tasca blando quelli medi hanno
trovato la chiave o no ha detto questo
bisogna accettarlo ha chiamato io so
dov'è la chiave non è che hanno cercati
perché se l'hanno trovata o no e va a
prenderlo corridoio riscopriamo quella
vuoto no io li odio schipa che sono
finito sul guarda dove sono dove le sue
vere dovere tutto bene che mi spara
storto ma lo storico prendiamo sul
minore tranquillo che sono sull'isola e
poi a ritorno nas hanno aperto torno su
una perdita non hanno aperto per i non
hanno ancora trovato ciò che la chiave
ruolo chiave io la chiave so dove l'ho
messa io poi ancora 9 stesa mica scemi
non li metti che l'ha presa bene nel suo
controllo noi che non lo centro di tutto
sulla scuola sta ancora qua se ancora
qua c'è ancora la chiave l'arguto gli
assi si tranquilla lascia spara che
aveva né io dai
italia
prezzo preso preso un piano perfetto
prato la traiettoria rega
la traiettoria perfetta madonna rende di
schiaffi mamma mia ma dolore mancato
madonna quando avevano creato mamma
hanno preso quattro volte spero di no
poi subito l'avreste l'isola e spero io
guardo da domani ci sta e non ho più
care il vice marello e rubano i falli
che non ne ha e la si indigna ma da loro
importantissima che non vuole che non è
la fine ma l'ho ucciso di tirare ancora
gli sparano loro si può dedicare le
spalle da loro spara spara spara spara
loro che che io sono giù non li posso
fare il pane sparate se disparate e
cadono bravi ancora la avvio che non
riparano è però 18 di colpirli 18 18
tutti colpiti 19 secondi e di farle io
io resisto quanto posso rega bravi bravi
bravi che non sia ancora un pelo ancora
un velo per un fiero di che colore ma
così a parte sono affondati dalla
fondati mamma
è un tipo che rimarremo piccoli che non
andiamo
il macaco ammazzando veloci a prendere i
tesori ragazzi ok lo nascosta qui
che figata l'hai fatta c'era beh
è tutto tesoro nella of radio attenzione
prendetelo non vorrei mai che arrivano e
se lì non c'è niente dentro sito non è
finita quindi ragazzo vale quel che
quello che avete visto era il bottino
unito a il raid che abbiamo alla fine
vinto noi ea tutti i bottini delle varie
navi che abbiamo buttato giù è stato uno
dei raid difficili della vita perché
arrivavano oltre che il raid è difficile
di suo arrivavano navi di continuo e
quindi abbiamo buttato giù ed eravamo in
tre praticamente quindi ciao né proprio
quindi quel tesoro
l'insieme del raid più dei dei tesori
degli altri che abbiamo preso è adesso
stavamo andando a consegnarlo ma non è
finita qui purtroppo c'è una seconda
parte che è mettere un po più avanti
quindi ragazzuoli spero che vi sia
piaciuto come quanto mi piace anche
l'altro candidato si sono travestiti
federici che diamo hanno proceduto da
ragazzi
[Musica]